an important reason why conditional
probabilities are very useful is that
they allow us to divide and conquer they
allow us to split complicated
probability models into simpler
submodules that we can then analyze one
at a time
let me remind you of the total
probability theorem that has this
particular flavor we divide our sample
space into three disjoint events a 1 a 2
and a 3 and these events form a
partition of the sample space that is
they exhaust all possibilities they
correspond to three alternative
scenarios one of which is going to occur
and then we may be interested in a
certain event B that event B may occur
under either scenario and the total
probability theorem tells us that we can
calculate the probability of event B by
considering the probability that it
occurs under any given scenario and
weigh those probabilities according to
the probabilities of the different
scenarios now let us bring random
variables into the picture let us fix a
particular value little X and let the
event B be the event that a random
variable takes on this particular value
let us now translate the total
probability theorem to this situation
first the picture will look slightly
different our event B has been replaced
by the particular event that we are now
considering now what is this probability
the probability that event B occurs
having fixed the particular choice of
little X is the value of the PMF at that
particular X how about this probability
here this is the probability that the
random variable capital X takes on the
value little X that's what the PMF is
but in the conditional universe so we're
dealing with the conditional PMF and so
on with the other terms
so this equation here is just the usual
total probability theorem but translated
into PMF notation
now this version of the total
probability theorem of course is true
for all values of little X this means
that we can now multiply both sides of
this equation by X and and then sum over
all possible choices of X we recognize
that here we have the expected value of
the random variable X now we do the same
thing to the right hand side we multiply
by X and then we sum over all possible
values of X this is going to be the
first term and then we will have similar
terms now what do we have here this
expression is just the conditional
expectation of the random variable X
under the scenario that event a 1 has
occurred so what we have established is
this particular formula which is called
the total expectation theorem it tells
us that the expected value of a random
variable can be calculated by
considering different scenarios finding
the expected value under each of the
possible scenarios and weigh them wave
the scenarios according to their
respective probabilities the picture is
like this under each scenario the random
variable X has a certain conditional
expectation we take all these into
account we wave them according to their
corresponding probabilities and we add
them up to find the expected value of X
so we can divide and conquer we can
replace a possibly complicated
calculation of an expected value by
hopefully simpler calculations under
each one of possible scenarios let me
illustrate the idea by a simple example
let us consider this PMF and let us try
to calculate the expected value of the
Associated random variable
one way to divide and conquer is to
define an event a one which is that our
random variable takes values in this set
and another event a two which is that a
random variable takes values in that set
let us now apply the total expectation
theorem let us calculate all the terms
that are required first we find the
probabilities of the different scenarios
the probability of event a e1 is 1/9
plus 1/9 plus 1/9 which is 1/3 and the
probability of event a 2 is 2/9 plus 2/9
plus 2/9 which adds up to 2/3
how about conditional expectations in a
universe where event a 1 has occurred
only these three values are possible
they had equal probabilities so in the
conditional model they will also have
equal probability so we will have a
uniform distribution over the set 0 1 2
by symmetry the expected value is going
to be in the middle so this expected
value is equal to 1 and by a similar
argument the expected value of X under
the second scenario is going to be the
midpoint of this range which is equal to
7 and now we can apply the total
probability theorem and write that the
expected value of x is equal to the
probability of the first scenario times
the expected value under the first
scenario plus the probability of the
second scenario times the expected value
under the second scenario in this case
by breaking down the problem in these
two sub cases the calculations that were
required were somewhat simpler than if
you were to proceed directly of course
this is a rather simple example but as
we go on with this course we will apply
the total probability theorem in much
more interesting and complicated
situations